you know it turns out that the Red Cross
is not looking for a nightclub promoter
Doctors Without voters are they're
looking for credible doctors not you
know DJs or promoters
so I remember being so uh
dejected by the rejections and then one
organization wrote me back and said if
you are willing to pay us 500 a month to
volunteer
and if you're willing to go live in the
poorest country in the world a country
I'd never even heard of called Liberia
and it was at the bottom of the United
Nations development chart because it had
just come out of a 14-year Civil War and
there was finally data on the country
that they could stack rank it at the
bottom of the world
and they said we are taking a medical
Mission into this country and we'll take
you if you pay us
[Music]
what's up uh I have Scott Harrison here
we've been I don't know maybe planning
to do at least in my head I've been
planning to do an episode like this for
a long time
um so I invited myself on let's be
honest you did invite yourself on but
that's not that I love about you that's
because I like you you are you're also
like kind of unashamed you you are
unashamed at like doing getting the
right thing done
um I met this guy once and he said if
your intentions are good you can get
away with anything and I don't know if
that's you know I don't know if that's
100 true but I I do think it's uh it's
it's a good motto don't be don't be too
shy so yes you invite yourself on but I
think it's gonna be a good one well the
alternative was you want people to die a
bad water so I mean right yeah well
which one is it
I'm just kidding um Scott's a good
friend uh we met through uh mutual
friend Michael Birch and then uh I went
on a trip to Africa with Scott and saw
the work that he was doing so that was
kind of cool I'll say this so a lot of
people click on this podcast because
they're schemers and dreamers they're
trying to figure out how to make money
and we don't shy away from the fact that
we enjoyed making money and we enjoy the
game of business
I think for most people here's their
mindset coming in it's going to be
charity episode uh okay you know maybe
if I'm in the mood but I'm gonna tell
you this so that person who's a little
on the fence let me tell you this right
now
you're gonna love this episode way more
than the normal one for two reasons
the first is You're Gonna Be Inspired
Scott's story is is very inspiring I've
heard him tell it many times I'm giving
gonna give him the opportunity to tell
it here because it's kind of one of
these like real life movies in a way and
um he started off as a not so do-gooder
and turned into a very do-gooder and I
think the story is very good
um and two he's basically he's an
entrepreneur and he took an
entrepreneurial approach to charity
which I think very few uh I know I know
personally of very few examples of that
and he's a very good Storyteller and for
all of you people who reach out to me
saying oh Sean I love your stories
well the master is here he's a much
better Storyteller than me so if you
take nothing else away from this you'll
pick up a lot on storytelling that's
those are my promises to you uh Scott
how did I do you think that's a high
music properly yeah I know no pressure
luckily you've told this story once or
twice before well I okay I like schemers
and dreamers so I was definitely a
schemer and dreamer at 18 years old I
was born in Philadelphia raised in a
Conservative Christian family and when I
was four my mom passed out on the
bedroom floor due to a carbon monoxide
gas leak in our house so we just moved
into this new house my dad was excited
because it was reducing his commute he
wanted to spend more time with me have a
big family and she was the canary in the
coal mine which her her unconsciousness
led to the discovery of this gas leak
and life was never the same again mom
never really affected her because she
was at home all the time you guys 24 7.
that's right she was unpacking boxes
from the move you know putting frames on
the walls uh dad was working you know
long hours at a job I was at school
playing with my friends at their houses
and she was she she bore the brunt of it
and we my diamond actually got sick so
we had some weird food allergies some
migraines but she got really sick and
this led to the discovery of the gas
leak my dad ripped out the furnace with
his bare hands he threw it out on the
curb and from that point on her immune
system was irreparably disabled and
unfortunately I have 40 years of
experience with the 3M family of masks
so my mom was always masked from that
point on charcoal mass n95 mass
everything chemical made her sick so she
was able to survive by creating
isolation rooms for herself this sounds
strange but my mom lived in a tin foil
covered bathroom and she slept on an
army cot that had been washed in baking
soda 20 times she was so sensitive that
if she wanted to read a book I would
have to either bake her book in the oven
or set it outside for a couple days in
the sun to get that smell of print out
then I would knock on the door I would
hear the tin foil rustle I would hand
her the lightly baked book and with her
mask on and a pair of gloves she would
receive the book for me and shut the
door so all that to say a very weird
childhood uh in a caregiver role doing
the cooking doing the cleaning you know
helping my dad my dad was an amazing
loyal man stuck buyer I believe that one
day God would make sense of all this and
you know my mom just lived with this for
the rest of her life so you know the
first kind of chapter of my life if
you'd run into me as a young teenager I
was gonna be a doctor I would get a cure
mom and everybody else sick with a
condition like hers
uh instead I became a schemer and a
dreamer and at 18. yeah I moved to New
York City and just had that wake up
moment now it's my turn now it's my turn
to break the rules I don't want to take
care of anyone anymore I want to take
care of myself and I want to have sex
and I want to do drugs and I want to
drink and I want to be rich and famous
and I stumbled into this job as a New
York City nightclub promoter where you
had a pretty good shot at achieving
those markers of success and I I became
really good at throwing parties uh at
the high end selling thousand dollar
bottles of Cristal selling 25 vodka Red
Bulls that cost us 25 cents and creating
spaces for movie stars and actors and
musicians and you know fashion Moguls
and designers to party
and you know it couldn't have been more
opposite maybe from the the slightly
repressed Christian upbringing
and you know a picture of my life 10
years later was me in a DJ booth with a
famous DJ I'm spraying champagne down
over the crowd puppies at table one
Jay-Z's at table three and I'm at table
two thinking I'm a rock star because we
had prettier girls at our table Ben
Jay-Z or puppy and and this was you know
it was dinner at 10 the Nightclub at 12
and then after hours at five a.m and to
bed at noon taking Ambien to come down
with a whole lot of self-loathing you
know if it caught up to us which it it
did you know far too often towards the
end of that so uh it was 10 years for me
to realize that
I had made a mess in my life I had come
so far from the spirituality from the
morality that my parents had tried to
instill in me so far from wanting to
become a doctor to help others
and one day half my body went numb
and uh you know maybe no surprise to
anybody listening as I just described
what I was doing but I just remember
thinking like I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die I've been living like I'm gonna live
forever and now I'm gonna die in a week
I've got some brain tumor I've got
something very wrong with me because I
can't feel half my body
and I went to doctors and had MRIs and
CT scans and you know they hooked diodes
up to me in electromagnetic pulsing all
that they couldn't figure out anything
wrong with me
uh but it was a wake-up call Sean that
if I did die
my Tombstone the best it could read
would be here lies a man who's gotten a
million people wasted because the only
thing I had to show before when you were
in the doctor's office and you fill out
the little form where you're just like
yes on all the questions it's like have
you in the last six months consumed any
drugs okay I remember being brutally
honest yeah right because I think
everybody kind of cheats a little like
how many alcoholic drinks right you
shave that by a half typically I think I
was honest and like how many alcoholic
drinks like 165 a week you know
something just yeah how many packs of
cigarettes two and a half a day
um you know anyway they couldn't find
anything wrong with me but this led to
you know a pretty radical life change
and and maybe the close of chapter two
as this sycophantic hedonistic nightclub
promoter living only for himself
um and I I wondered whether I could
start life over at 28 and
really ask myself what would the
opposite of my life look like you know I
realized a pivot was not in order yo
this was this was not a small course
correction that needed to happen this
was like do and think and say the 180
degree opposite of everything you've
done and thought and said for the last
10 years and see how that plays out and
I live for these kind of like
these moments these self-talk moments I
think most of life is just in my own
head it's me it's me with me and we're
having a conversation and so a lot of
times it's small talk it's surface level
stuff and then there are these times
where I have the like the real
conversation with myself in my head do
you do you remember what that like well
those days or like what made you really
like have that that that conversation
with yourself at that point yeah yeah
well there was a faith piece so I
started praying again and you know kind
of going back and like hey what do I
believe any of that stuff from childhood
you know there was a lot of religion
there was a lot of rules you know but
but there was a lot of good in there as
well so I sort of you know try to kind
of come back to Faith again so there was
a lot of prayer like you know God are
you there uh and what should I be doing
and is there is there anything else for
me and I remember the self-talk uh
really saying okay well if you're if
you're exploring the opposite of your
life
um what would that look like and I
thought well it would be volunteering
on a humanitarian mission in the poorest
country in the world that was the spec
that would be the opposite of a
nightclub you know bottles and models
lifestyle
and I remember from a I I was I'd taken
some time driving just aimlessly North
trying to you know find myself I wound
up in Maine in an internet cafe on
Moosehead Lake uh with dial-up Dell
computers and I started applying to
humanitarian Aid organizations that I
tangentially heard of over the decade
certainly not that I had given any money
to but Doctors Without Borders saved the
children Oxfam World Vision the Red
Cross and I I was very clear that this
is what I wanted to do give one year
of the 10 years that I had selfishly
wasted or lived and see if I could be
useful
well maybe no surprise I was denied by
the first-hand organizations you know it
turns out that the Red Cross is not
looking for a nightclub promoter Doctors
Without Borders are they're looking for
credible doctors not you know DJs or
promoters
so I remember being so uh
dejected by the rejections and then one
organization wrote me back and said if
you are willing to pay us 500 a month to
volunteer
and if you're willing to go live in the
poorest country in the world a country
had never even heard of called Liberia
and it was at the bottom of the United
Nations development chart because it had
just come out of a 14-year Civil War and
there was finally data on the country
that they could stack rank it at the
bottom of the world
and they said we are taking a medical
Mission into this country and we'll take
you if you pay us every month and uh the
the job or the volunteer role I signed
up for was a photojournalist so I was
going to be taking pictures in writing
and I was always a pretty good writer
and a pretty good hobby photographer you
know through the club club years and I'd
gotten a degree part-time at NYU for
that because it was it was the easiest
you basically did the real life version
I don't even watch Seinfeld but I know
about this episode where George is like
Jerry of doing the opposite now whatever
I used to do I do the opposite you
basically had the real live version of
that where you're like go from New York
City nightlife You Know Rich famous fast
living to I'm gonna go to the poorest
country on Earth pay to volunteer and uh
and basically donate a year of my time
just to kind of course correct and like
break my own frame and shift just it
sounds like you didn't even have like a
long-term plan or like this Grand Vision
for yourself I was like I just need to
shift
like where this direction I'm going now
into some I need a swerve in a hard turn
and then a couple things happen yeah
that's exactly right I wouldn't have
told you more than a year of line of
sight
um I met the chief medical officer so I
was going to be living on a hospital
ship a 500 foot converted ocean liner
that was 50 plus years old so not you
know not a nice Cruise liner
um and it had been gutted and turned
into a state-of-the-art hospital with a
very simple idea for this charity let's
sail a giant hospital ship with the best
doctors in the world on their vacation
time and let's take it to people who
can't afford Medical Care
and and because we can control the
environment let's bring them on the
hospital ship perform these
life-changing surgeries and then set
them you know back on land with
transformed lives and transformed health
so I met the guy who is running this
whole thing and his name was Dr Gary
Parker and I learned that he was a
plastic surgeon from California who had
heard about this opportunity and he
signed up for three months
and when I walked up the gangway of this
hospital ship to to surrender my
passport he had been there 21 years
so he never went back to his California
plastic surgery practice and he
dedicated two decades of his life to
this work so I remember just thinking
what if that's me what if it's not a
year and I wanted to know everything I
could about him and what two decades of
service would look like or feel like or
the impact that a person could have so
my third day there
um is the patient screening so the the
ship's arrival has been announced by an
advanced team Flyers have been posted
throughout the country
and we have been given the football
stadium in the center of town the soccer
stadium by the government to triage the
people who might come to visit our
doctors now I know we have 1500
available surgery slots to fill I
remember thinking to myself like are
there 1500 sick people with facial
tumors or cleft lips or blind or lame uh
with Leprosy like you know that sounds
like a lot of people and I remember at 5
15 or 5 30 a.m putting on hospital
scrubs it was still pitch black out
jumping into this Convoy of Land Rovers
with doctors and surgeons and nurses and
we kind of snaked through the city
and we came to the stadium and there
were 5 000 people standing in the dark
in the parking lot waiting for us to
open the doors
and that was such a powerful moment for
me realizing oh crap we're gonna send 3
500 of these people home
without seeing a doctor without any
answer
for their Affliction and I later learned
to uh you're probably used to having a
long line outside the door that was a
good difference this was a bad thing now
the parallels you know there have been
some interesting ones um I later learned
some of these people had walked for more
than a month with their children from
neighboring countries just hoping that a
doctor might save their child's life
so I remember Dr Gary said to me focus
on the hope you know don't focus on the
3 500 people we're gonna send home focus
on the 1500 people who are going to help
and that's what I really did for that
first year on the ship and I was
documenting every single one of them
before surgery and after surgery for the
medical Library
and that you know Mercy Ships would be
able to use those photos to raise money
and spread awareness to the work the
other cool thing that happened was I was
blasting my club list of 15 000 emails
with pictures of facial tumors and
flesh-eating disease and leprosy you
know being healed and you know or or
patients being operated on and you know
back then email open rates were like a
hundred percent
so there were definitely a lot of
unsubscribes you know I signed up for
that cool Prada party you threw once but
not like the tumor party
um but then you know most people were
intrigued they were fascinated I had no
idea that there were doctors on a ship
saving people's lives how do I get a
piece of this how do I sponsor a surgery
how do I come on the ship like you I
remember somebody riding me from Chanel
once she's like I sit here in a brightly
lit cosmetic headquarters and I'm
weeping you know because I want more
like I want more
than to sell makeup every day I want
more for my life I want more purpose so
I learned that maybe the same gift of
promoting getting people to stand
outside a Velvet Rope to cue to hope to
get into a nightclub telling the story
that if you came in my club and you
spent thousands of dollars and you left
with a cute boy or a cute girl then your
life had meaning you know that same
maybe gift or skills of promoting could
be used to promote something entirely
different
and Redemptive and important for other
people
so the year ended and I just signed up
for a second year because I didn't know
what was next so let me go do this again
for another year
and that was when I found water
so the second year I got off of the ship
I spent more and more time I bought a
motorcycle uh so I'm driving around West
Africa Liberia you know with 14 000
United Nations peacekeepers and soldiers
and I've got this little press badge and
I'm spending time in these rural areas
and I see the water people are drinking
and they're drinking from swamps and
ponds and rivers brown green viscous
water
and I learned two things I learned half
the country is drinking dirty water
and I learned half the disease in the
country is because people are drinking
dirty water
so you know for contrast you know a year
previously I'd been selling Vos water
for ten dollars a bottle
to people who would just order 20
bottles for the table and not open any
of them because they were drinking vodka
or champagne
so there was just something so you know
profoundly uh contrastful of watching a
human drink dirty water that was making
them sick in real time
and knowing the excess of my former life
and I remember showing these photos to
Dr Gary and I'm like Dr Gary no wonder 5
000 sick people were standing outside a
parking lot of a stadium you should see
what they're drinking and he said yeah I
know and in fact a billion people drink
this water every day one in six people
alive on the planet he said why don't
you go do something about it
why don't you make this your mission
instead of raising money for you know
the next 1500 surgeries on this ship why
don't you just go get everybody in the
world clean water
he said yeah something like you'll be
the you'd be the greatest Medical
Professional in the the history of the
world if you just brought people the
most basic need for health the most
basic need for life
and I was 30 at the time I'm like oh
well okay Dr Gary that sounds good you
know and I came back to New York City
and said that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna try to bring clean and save
drinking water to every single human on
earth before I die because that seems
like a good idea and it'd be great if 5
000 people didn't have to stand outside
a stadium if 3 500 people didn't have to
get turned away because they had clean
water in their Villages and that was
really the start of Charity water you
know now 17 years ago
and you
um this story I would say two things one
is your story is so good that the first
time I heard it I thought that sounds
almost too good like too good to be true
like the story is almost like Hollywood
in that in that sense
um
as I got to know you I learned that
you're the real deal I went with you to
Africa I saw the wells that you guys
have created I saw the drinking water we
did the water carry of you know how far
the women and children have to carry
water that's not even that clean but the
cleaner water back to back home just so
they have water uh you know we saw the
schools that were like you know now
could function because they had this we
saw so much stuff so I've seen the
impact of it on that side yeah I
remember thinking this this almost
sounds too good to be true it turns out
to be the real deal that's the first
thing I want to say the second thing is
when you have that moment where you're
like all right here's what I should do
with my life
I know I've felt this I'm sure other
people felt this too the difference
between what you feel like you should do
and what you actually do is often held
back by some sort of fear or levitation
did you like once you left Africa and
you get back to the to New York
did doubt creep in or did you have any
second thoughts of like yeah well maybe
I'll just send the check and go get a
job somewhere like you know or were you
really are you just wired differently
where you were just sort of gung-ho like
no I'm doing this I think what helped
was that I had lived there for almost a
year you know you hear about a lot of
people that go on a mission trip with
their church and they spend five days in
Guatemala or in Africa five days is not
enough to change right you change
everything about your life for most
people
um a year of immersive
proximity
to an issue was so there was a
responsibility to do something about
what I'd seen that that took more than a
week or even a month right um so I I
remember coming home
um in fact the ship was sailing to South
Africa while it was going to be dry
docked every year so they would kind of
make repairs on the ship and everybody
went on vacation to wine region for a
month I'm like I don't want to waste my
time doing that I'm gonna go back to New
York City and I'm gonna put on a Gallery
exhibition of all the photos that I've
taken and I'm gonna invite all my club
friends in and I'm gonna ask him for
money
and I did that I got a gallery donated
in Chelsea I got a bunch of you know uh
printers to donate you know high-res
giant photographs and I put together 108
of my before and afters in a gallery and
I invited everybody from the clubs to
come in and we raised about a hundred
thousand dollars and then I went back on
the ship to show people what we had done
with their money right uh to kind of
follow the donation and so let's talk
about the approach that you used to
build Cherry water so first let's zoom
out at this point charity water has been
around for how many years and how much
money has been uh donated and how many
people have been given clean drinking
water since this moment we're in year 17
just started year 17. we've raised 750
million dollars and we've helped uh 16.8
million people get clean water
amazing and and in the world there are
770 million people without water so it's
now one in ten people alive as we record
this for drinking dirty water 82 of them
live in rural areas so 17 years later
now back to year one of that your
approach so you took a very interesting
approach to this I want to start with a
quote that I had heard you say once it's
like this toothpaste quote uh you'll
you'll tell it better than me but I
remember I still remember this either
you first told me this like eight years
ago or something and that one stood out
to me it stuck with me ever since then
you want to say the quotes yeah this was
Nick Kristoff from the New York Times
toothpaste is peddled with far more
sophistication
than all the world's life-saving causes
exactly is better than Doctors Without
Borders at telling their story
right the marketing the sophistication
the photography the story the
storytelling all of it that goes into
selling random commodity products
deodorant toothpaste
um and I I what I what stood out to me
when I kind of encountered what you guys
were doing at charity water was it was
like Best in Class marketing Best in
Class product Best in Class storytelling
like you would find with the way that
you know
traditional consumer package good brands
are run but you were doing it with
charity and I had never seen that I was
used to going to a charity website that
was some old and crusty Craigslist
looking site and I push a button and it
asked me for money through some old
payment method that I don't even know
how to use pages long right and then I'm
like clicking accept accept I have no
idea where this money is going never
hear from them again
um you know and that was my charity
experience and then charity water is
very very different so talk about how
you decided to approach it from like
first principles and what were those
like core tenants uh that you you built
on top of well I had the advantage of
not knowing what I was doing uh with
many entrepreneurs that start you know
anything it becomes that is the
entrepreneurial Advantage I didn't know
any better I didn't come from the
established so I knew nothing about
traditional philanthropy how to set up a
charity actually went and bought the
yellow dummies book you know non-profits
for dummies okay and then I bought HTML
for dummies because I'm like well I
don't have money for a web designer so I
need to also so you know build our
website so I was living on a closet
floor at the time in SoHo New York my
old Club partner took me in for free
rent and I was sleeping on his walk-in
closet and but I had a very clear
Mission so if you'd run into me 17 years
ago I'm gonna bring clean water to
everybody in the world same thing I'm
I'm saying you know now
um the as I talk to Everyday people who
worked at MTV or VH1 at the time who
worked at Sephora who worked at Chase
Bank I realized they were cynical and
skeptical about charities
they just didn't trust Charities writ
large and I remember coming across a USA
Today poll found 42 percent of Americans
just flat out said distrustful of
charities
70 of Americans in a more recent poll
said they believe Charities waste their
money
so seven out of ten
potentially generous people think
Charities are wasting their donations so
I thought this was a huge opportunity
and a new business model could solve
some of this uh skepticism or speak to
the skeptic so I thought well what if we
could open up two separate bank accounts
and in One bank account I would raise
all of that nasty overhead the staff
salaries the office cost the toner for
the Epson copy machine the flights to
Africa and Indian Asian where we'd
eventually build our projects what if I
could raise that in a separate bank
account and then in the main bank
account a hundred percent of every
donation whether it was a dollar or a
pound or a Euro or a million dollars or
a million pounds or a million euros
could go directly to build water
projects that saves people's lives
and you know nobody was doing this at
the time I mean this would have you know
made us different than 99.99 of
charities in the world
um because it's very difficult to do but
I just thought this would be clear I
could say to a six-year-old go sell
lemonade turn in 75 cents at all 75
cents will go directly to help people
get clean water so that was kind of
number one idea number two was then kind
of realizing wow money's not fungible so
we can build technology tools to track
these small amounts of money
down to the project that they funded and
I remember meeting the the founder of
Google Earth and he pressed this
Medallion into my palm so charity Water
started right before Google Earth and
Google Maps and he says you know I'm
building a place where you can put every
single well every water point and you
can show people where their money went
so I'm like great we're gonna be the
first charity to Geo locate every
completed project and we're gonna build
the most transparent charity the world
has ever seen so proof became the second
pillar and then the third thing was this
idea of building an epic brand uh
Charities so often use shame and guilt
to Pedal their Wares where would the
apple of Charities where was the Nike
you know Nike doesn't sell shoes by
telling people they're fat and lazy
you know Nike sells Shoes by telling
inspirational stories of people
overcoming adversity now Nike believes
if you have one leg you can win a
marathon you know if you have one arm
you can win the shot put competition at
the Olympics with your other arm and you
know Nike believes greatness is inside
you and that's the way that they market
and someone's like maybe I should turn
off the TV and stop eating Cheetos and
try and go run a quarter of a mile
so I I wanted charity water to be
modeled on You Know The Whimsy of Virgin
the kind of beautiful design of apple
and then this you know this opportunity
or inspiration of of Nike and I just
didn't see it out there so brand was
kind of the third thing the third pillar
and then to actually get the work done I
believed you know as we built Wells and
built gravity fed systems and filtration
systems and it would need to be led by
the locals in each of these countries to
be culturally appropriate and
sustainable when you came with me to
Ethiopia there were 350 local staff
working on the charity water projects
running eight different drilling rigs
there wasn't a single person who looked
like you or me right uh in that entire
program of 350 people and we just
believed that we would create thousands
of local jobs as we scaled
um and our our role would be to get
people to care about this issue get
people to say it's not okay on my watch
that we are looking for water on a
planet over a hundred million miles away
and 770 million people
are risking their life every day because
they don't have clean water here on our
planet so our job would be to get people
to reject the apathy that you know is is
easy to assume with any of these
paralyzing Global issues and say let's
do something about this let's get
everybody on earth clean water like we
can all agree on that Republicans can
agree on that Democrats and independents
and Libertarians and Jews and Christians
and Muslims and atheists and Mormons
like everybody can think that clean
drinking water is a good idea
so it started in a nightclub I mean the
only idea I had 17 years ago was to
throw my 31st birthday party I got the
club donated I got open bar donated and
then I charged everybody 20 bucks to get
in as a donation and at the end of that
night we collected fifteen thousand
dollars in this big Plexi box and we
counted it and then we counted it again
and then we photographed everybody
counting it and then we took 100 of the
money to Uganda and we built our first
well and then we sent the photos and the
GPS coordinates of that well back to the
700 people and we say you did this
here's where your twenty dollars went
and that sounds so simple but that was
so revolutionary
people never expected to hear from the
charity again I mean they went to some
party in a club for some dudes 31st
birthday and they threw 20 bucks in a
bin and that idea we said let's just put
that at the core of Charity water and in
everything we do let's try to connect
people to what their money accomplished
to the people who they helped
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
and so you you kick it off like that
with a nightclub go back you go back to
the to your kind of roots as as far as
what do I know how to do okay I can
throw a great party but this time I'll
I'll do it with a Twist
and then tell the story about Mark
Zuckerberg and Michael Birch and trying
to uh scale this up because I thought
this was an amazing story yeah and this
is where
at some point your Genius business model
of not searching all the overheads
separate and letting all the donations
100 of the donations go to the cause
sounds good in theory but there's a
reason why Charities don't do this
because it's hard to cover the overheads
so talk about how you got into a little
bit of a pickle and then what happened
from there yeah so about a year and a
half in well let's just say the 100
model was working and we'd raised a few
million dollars just right out of the
gate people love that idea
um in the other bank account a lot
harder to raise that overhead so we had
a moment where we had 887 thousand
dollars ready to go out to build water
projects and we're about to miss payroll
and the overhead bank account and it was
interesting the advice I was getting
from people was hey go borrow from that
887. right I mean you gotta pay your
people right like you'll pay it back
later write a little IOU in that account
and I remember thinking if we borrow one
penny we've compromised our integrity
there's a crack at the foundation and I
don't want to work here and nobody will
want to work here again so I'm just
going to shut the charity down and say
that this business model didn't work and
I started calling lawyers to say like
how do you wind down a charity 18 months
in because all the naysayers were right
it's too hard getting people excited
about overhead at the same time I had
just come up with this idea of trying to
scale the birthday party but not a
birthday party in a nightclub taking it
online
and uh for year two uh or the the one
year anniversary of Charity water I
donated my 32nd birthday and instead of
throwing a party I just asked everyone
to give 32 dollars for my 32nd birthday
and I wound up raising 60 Grand
4X because a lot of people had 32
dollars to give especially if they could
see exactly where it went right so I had
uh Googled you know top three social
networks and you know Myspace was number
one at the time so I emailed Tom uh
Facebook was number two emailed Zuck uh
it's like called bibo that I hadn't
heard of was number three so I remember
scraping uh Michael Birch's name from
The Domain registry you know who is uh
dot net and I emailed him and I said hey
I'm this kid I'm trying to bring clean
water to the world and I'd like
everybody on your social network to
donate their birthdays to my cause it's
your agent dollars 100 goes yeah this is
a great idea well duck didn't write me
back Tom didn't write me back Michael
did and he said I actually love this
idea and on the side I have this site
called Birthday alarm which reminds
people of their birthdays and um he said
you know the timing for me is terrible
right now but you know keep up the great
work and by the way the website design
looks awesome
so this was six months before the
bankruptcy moment and around this time
when we're about to wind down you know I
remember praying I'm like on my knees
like God I thought you gave me this
dream where's the money like show me the
money uh you show me the money in the
wrong bank account and uh I was praying
I had no faith uh that anything would
happen and at this time Michael burchton
turns up and he says hey I'm gonna be in
New York um I've got an hour you know
can I stop by and see your office and I
remember sitting with him and taking him
through a presentation on my laptop and
just being really honest about how hard
it was to raise money for overhead
and I remember thinking he just didn't
like me I mean he was British you know
he wasn't smiling not not a lot of
warmth uh or encouragement but two days
later he emails me at midnight and he
says hey I really enjoyed meeting you I
just wired a million dollars into your
overhead account
I remember logging on to the bank and I
saw it one comma zero zero zero it was
13 months of overhead funding so we went
from insolvent and he said I think he
said keep rocking just you just need
more time love the idea you just need
more time and again that was 750 million
dollars ago and today we have 131
entrepreneurs and and families that pay
all the overhead
and we have never been close to the line
since
uh and and you know we grow that group
by selecting 20 new entrepreneurs and 20
new families or so every single year as
the organization grows and you know
Michael and zochi been very generous
they've given over 20 million dollars
they've come and come to 14 or 15
countries with me now bringing their
kids all over the world to see the
impact that they've they've made but
that was and that was that was a moment
I've asked Michael I was like you know
you've done all these different projects
so he did multiple internet companies he
uh he did the battery did the battery so
he's got this members club like a
physical building a giant beautiful 60
000 square foot building he's done you
know 100 Investments whatever as as like
you know what's your favorite what's the
best thing you've done
um
and instantly he just goes charity water
he goes uh yeah he goes the most
fulfilling work that I've done is
basically help you know donating and
then helping helping Scott and and
taking my family my kids to Africa I
think they go like almost every year or
every other year or something like that
to go and see the work and the projects
and he's like I love those trips with my
family my kids love it it's taught them
so much and uh you know he's like that's
the best thing I've done hands down and
I thought that was pretty impressive
here's the guy who's made like a billion
dollars and built social networks with
you know whatever millions and millions
of users and all that good stuff and and
I thought that was pretty uh pretty
remarkable and it sounds like
because when I met you
uh I went to one of your events and then
I went to the Ethiopia trip with you and
the Ethiopia trip you know it was like
the who's who was like you know famous
Tech founders
actors actresses people from Hollywood
people from the music industry and
Ferris was on that trip I think that's
such a fun group of people yeah it was a
kind of an amazing group and um you know
just like the kind of bus ride
conversations were were just incredible
for the group and then
um
and then I played Wonderwall at the fire
people saw that I only know three of the
four chords of Wonderwall and and so
they we go there and I'm like this is an
incredible way to like you know the best
products in the world are products where
you can either show somebody a before
and after photo even better you just put
a product in their hands or even better
what you were doing which was if I let
you see it you're gonna believe and so
what have you learned in that process of
like going from almost at almost
bankruptcy to down raising 750 million
dollars for charity which by the way is
a fraction of what we need to raise to
make the impact that we want to make so
you know 17 million people that's great
that's 1 47th of the way there so you
know we are we believe we're in like the
second inning of this right I looked at
the 27 stock a 27 year Justin Khan
tweeted this a couple years ago 27 year
stock chart of Amazon
seven percent of the value was created
in the first 20 years
93 of the value years 21 through 27. so
I you know things take time you know and
we believe that yeah this is just a mile
marker on you know hopefully the
expansiveness of the charity water
community and the generosity that is yet
untapped as we again try to get
everybody clean water I mean there's
probably nobody listening that thinks
people should die by drinking bad water
simply because of where they were born
right we all agree and what is the cost
to give someone clean drinking water
rough I I know you I remember there was
a number and then and then I remember
you were like hey that number's outdated
it doesn't take into account these other
things let's raise it and I remember
being like well I don't know that do we
want to should we just round the number
and you're like no we don't round the
number we just say what the actual cost
is like yeah I I really appreciate the
Integrity of it uh this year was it's
forty dollars to give one person clean
water on average we work across 22
countries I think last year's actual was
39.67.
and so so forty dollars and that's for a
year or that's for a lifetime that's for
10 10 plus years you know for the life
of the project some of these projects
you can change you can absolutely change
somebody's life 40 bucks I know and um
talk about some of the things that
you've tried so now let's kind of go
into the the slightly entrepreneurial uh
section of like you know stories of
stuff you've tried or are opportunities
that you see
um more in the spirit of kind of how we
typically brainstorm things around here
yeah I mean we've you know innovation
has been a real core of the organization
as you say trying new things we made one
of the first virtual reality films seven
years ago this is before they had VR
cameras that you could buy we got GoPros
donated made a modified rig and shot a
Six-Day Journey where a 13 year old girl
gets clean water for the first time in
her life we debuted that at a gala where
we put headsets on 400 people in Black
Tie we press press play and
synchronicity we took them all to
Ethiopia for this week of you know water
magic and then the minute the film ended
we just asked them for money and raised
a couple million dollars so you know
that that was a fun one
um you know a couple years ago we got
into the Bitcoin space and we started a
trust uh the Bitcoin water trust where
we raised a hundred Bitcoin to start and
we said we're gonna lock them all up in
Cold Storage until at least 2025. so
we're not going to sell it charity water
Charities typically when you give them
stock you know they immediately
liquidate who are we to ever take a
position on any asset right right and we
said we're gonna take a position on this
and we think you know there will be
people who would only give us a Bitcoin
donation you know to hold past you know
the next having and and and and maybe
even longer but would never give us a
Bitcoin you know to immediately
liquidate they'd rather give us cash for
some other asset
um so we raised over a hundred there and
that's that that campaign is open is
still going with that same promise that
a hundred percent will then you know get
unlocked at some point 20 25 and Beyond
and then go to have as much impact as as
possible
um gosh I mean we you know the birthday
idea raised over a hundred million
dollars
um by getting over a million people
involved just in that simple idea and
that's now been taken by lots of other
Charities
and my birthday's in two weeks I want to
give up my birthday let's do it I'll be
your first donor all right it's it's at
least worth it to set up the page in 30
seconds is it still at my
charitywater.com or where do I go now to
do that I think you just I think it's
probably on the home page now okay
wonderful yeah so that's another way
people can get and then we have um we
have an amazing subscription Community
called the Spring
um which is that has really helped the
organization triple over the last uh
five years and it's I remember being in
a Land Rover with Daniel Eck from
Spotify and he's like Scott your
business model sucks every January one
all that money you raised last year your
ticker starts at zero you gotta go
re-raise all that and then grow he said
why don't you build a community of
people who will sign up every single
month to give what they can and that's
the spring that now has members from 149
countries and is really the core of so
much of our growth the average is about
30 bucks a month so it's it's a little
less than one person getting clean water
but there are a lot of people that can
give one person clean water every single
month and not even miss it not even
think about it you know it's two
netflixes and a Spotify right or two HBO
Maxes and uh and instead of you know
getting content that you probably don't
even need to watch more of anyway you
know humans are getting clean water as
100 of that goes so that's people could
learn more about that at thespring.com
and there's also a video there that's
gotten over 100 million views which is a
is a short telling of our story with
some of the visuals that you mentioned
and I'm going to ask you one impossible
question which is kind of like you know
you asked Michael Jordan how do you do
how do you do it right it's like you've
told me little things in passing around
because I I kind of admire your brand
building your storytelling and your
event thing also like we didn't even
talk about the events that you guys
throw and how those drum up so much
interest and passion and donations and
you had told me one thing about the
events that I shared on the podcast that
a lot of people liked which was when I
asked you why are your events so good
why why do people Rave about the events
and you said oh I got this from from Vic
my wife she she says uh
you know it's about the moments between
the moments
um and you gave me that little
philosophy and I don't even think I
understand 80 of that but we should get
my wife in here it's provocative right
it gives you something to think about
I'm curious do you feel like is there
anything that you've kind of is your
your personal philosophies or isms or
sort of like life hacks when it comes to
either the storytelling the sales the
marketing side the brand building like
do you have any other moments between
the moments that I can I could take with
me this time well I I think the more you
give the more you give
so I think it's like a muscle and
practicing generosity practicing saying
yes just makes you want to say yes more
it makes you want to help more people
um you know I think a lot of people just
they have the walls up oh my gosh if I
say yes to this charity I'm gonna say
next to the next one right yes to the
next one and like everybody's gonna be
asking me like that's okay try that you
know and and if if you have to take the
amount that you're giving down to all of
them so you can say yes to more try
encouraging a social entrepreneur try
encouraging someone who has mustered the
courage to ask you to support their run
or you know their son's leukemia
treatment or the food pantry or a cause
like water around the world like say yes
and it's a joy to give it it's it's a
blessing to give you know the first
three letters in the word fundraising
it's fun
like it should be fun to raise money for
important causes to raise money uh to
give money to end needless suffering
around the world and I think the more
you do it the more you want to do it
um and the more you say no the more
you're inclined to say no and miss out
right well I will uh I will take your
challenge I will say yes so I'm gonna
set up a birthday my birthday's in a
couple weeks I'm gonna set up a birthday
campaign right now I'm gonna put the
link in the description of this podcast
awesome I love it so if you if you love
this podcast if you love me normally
that we have this thing called The
Gentleman's Agreement or the lady's
understanding which is basically says go
subscribe to our Channel today it's a
little bit of a different uh Gentleman's
Agreement your agent dollars how old are
you gonna be 35 so
if you want to give me a gift 35 bucks
towards charity water I'm gonna put the
link in the description and then I will
donate 35 000 on top of whatever gets
donated from people to to charity water
as well man and so that will be my uh my
my gift uh and Scott thanks for coming
on I promise you I'd get you out of here
on time so I gotta I gotta wrap it here
but thanks for coming on so generous
that's that's really incredible that
means so much to me and uh and thank you
for kind of showing I don't know I've
learned a lot from you that's a little
bit of my education from you on on brand
building storytelling and doing things
you know like I don't know you you have
the you have a lot of Courage you do you
chose to spend your life doing something
that matters like you you didn't care
about this stuff but I remember when I
went to Ethiopia with you and we went to
one of the schools where well had been
built and literally when we were coming
in I was like are The Beatles behind us
what is this giant crowd huge crowd like
the whole town was there lined up and
literally I was like
Scott is like Jesus to them like there
were signs with your name and I was like
of course there should be because of the
impact and you know for somebody who you
work on the internet like I'm sitting
here in my boxers right now doing a
podcast like we live a pretty Charmed
Life uh we get to do things that are are
pretty pretty you know easy in the grand
History of the World
um
I think it's pretty easy just to be
disconnected from from reality and
what's going on for billions of people
out there and so you know I thank you
for for giving me that experience and uh
you know if anybody has the opportunity
to kind of turn a little bit of your
attention away from kind of the Twitter
and the tick tocks of the world and take
a look at what's going on in the world I
think it will it'll help you and kind of
make an impact for them the same way it
did for me
oh man I I appreciate the the chance to
to tell the story and thanks again for
your generosity that means that means a
lot to me and more more importantly the
people who will be on the receiving end
of it and if people want to go learn
more about you the charity shout out
where you want to send people to uh I
would just say charitywater.org and
thespring.com
okay awesome thanks Scott thanks man
thanks for having me
[Music]
foreign